you're gonna John checking out a bone
that's sticking out of the cliff the
hailstones are looking to put money in
the bank by finding valuable fossils in
the permafrost
it's the mammoth tip it gotta be out but
that's a free stuff there tree yep
tree sure does look like the end of one
doesn't see what he's got going here
look like a horn yeah that's another
good start well now here's something
interesting this is cut by people see
the cut they snapped it off here you can
see where they cleanly cut the base of
this by chopping it probably getting
themselves a specific piece and then
just toss this this was done a long time
ago this is all wet mud all this
permafrost here is melting like crazy
new stuff falls down every day all that
new stuff is 10,000 plus years old
sometimes you come out with little
pieces sometimes you come up with the
whole piece of tusks our owner some kind
of go far tooth or something This Is It
this is what we do play in the mud all
day as you can see over here there's a
big old Bluff with a whole lot of
permafrost our mammoth could have easily
gone and died and ten thousand years
later have us look for you today we'll
get a whole mammoth tusk er - looks
pretty nice we're getting to the
interesting parts there is a whole lot
of treasure out here